In ancient Rome they had tampons of wool,
In Indonesia, plants and Japanese women used rolled paper.
It has been commercially produced since the 1930s
and for life a woman consumes up to 12,000 of these products.
Is it really necessary?
Shouldn't we stop?
Mentruation is a common biological process involving half the population
but it still remains taboo.
The menstrual cycle is repeated about every 28 days
from puberty to menopause.
Thanks to the progesterone and estrogen, the uterine mucosa always gets stronger
as a preparation for a possible pregnancy.
But when a woman is not pregnant,
the level of progesterone drops and the mucosa separates.
Thus, menstrual blood from the uterine arteries also contains these particles.
This is not common in animals, menstruating very little of them.
Except as people, primates, bats, or brucons,
in most animals, the uterus becomes stronger only during pregnancy.
In menstruation, 30-90 ml of fluids leave the body,
and as the main method of capturing 81% of women use tampons,
occasionally along with inserts.
Tampons are made of very absorbent materials
reacting with water like cotton and silk.
But unlike them, the remainder of the tampon is not degradable.
This will create over 130 kg of waste for your life.
These materials also create a favorable environment for Staphylococcus bacteria.
This causes a rare but life-threatening disease
Toxic Shock Syndrome (TSS).
Blood supplies the uterus with neutralizing proteins
it reduces acidity and reduces the ability to destroy bacteria.
More than 2,200 TSS cases were officially reported in 1983,
but in 1997 there were only 5,
by knowing about swabs
such as the need to change after max. 8 hours
or selecting the lowest possible absorbency.
In addition, they can dry out the vagina and rub the skin,
which increases the risk of infection.
Women spend about 2 500 CZK a year on tampons and pads
and although they are necessary, they are often highly taxed.
The protests have already changed in countries like Canada,
but in some poorer countries girls cannot go to school.
In South Africa, 9 million girls at the age of 13-19 miss lessons
due to lack of hygiene needs or room for replacement.
They can be replaced with a menstrual cup
airtight container for blood collection for reuse.
It is significantly cheaper than tampons
and can be used for several years.
It changes after 12 hours
so women don't have to exchange it at school or work
and much less on the planet.
In a study with women between 19 and 40
that previously used tampons and replaced them with a cup for 3 cycles,
91% of them preferred it
and despite the need for adoption, they would recommend it.
Mentra's blood saves lives!
Scientists create diagnostic tests for home use
that from this blood recognize the beginnings of cancer, endometriosis,
reproductive and sexually transmitted diseases.
Stem cells of this blood
they are stronger than those of the bone marrow.
Up to 9 different cell types can be created.
Thus, menstrual blood can be an uncontrolled, easily accessible, cheap
and an ethical source of cells for regenerative medicine.
From taboo through "normal" to saving life.
Menstruation is actually great, don't you think?
If you want to learn how to manage physical pain
or emotional fluctuations in menstruation, find them at #AskKimberly.
In other videos as a therapist and emotional coach
I advise how on relationships.
Thanks to my brother Mitch for help,
follow us for more videos!
Subtitles: Hana Furmankova